hello everyone and welcome back to the
world rapid championship it's a game
from round 8 Magnus Carlsen vs Czech
grandmaster a victory as Nichkhun I was
going to show a game between the leaders
chakra marvin van cow but the two of
them agreed to a draw like very early on
in the opening phase of the game like in
they played 1010 moves and agreed to a
draw so no point in showing that so we
have this game Carson versus lozenge so
without further ado let's check it out
and the Carson again goes for his London
system sorry about that
like he did against von cow although
against how he yeah he really struggled
for that draw but okay d5 Knight to f3
Knight to f6 Bishop f4 end version of
the f5 the so-called double London with
III east six and not Knight B to d2 I
will rush up to e7 biological Bishop to
d6
is is pretty much played all the time in
nowadays but Bishop d7
a rare remove now and okay Carson goes
for Knight to e5 and here some moves
have been played by black in this
position but hh5 has never been played
here and it is as almost six that we
have a completely new game so Carson
continues developing Bishop d3 we have
Bishop captures Knight captures and now
Knight B to d7
we have Quinta e 2 and now nice the e
for getting that night to it to a very
nice square with h3 and now Knight
captures on d2 with Queen captures and
now Bishop to d6 offering a trade of
bishops as well which will double up his
deep on but it will it will improve his
presence in the center so Bishop
captures the C captures now if you want
you can you can push 'if I've pretty
much right away
Magnus castles Queen side and the now H
for now preventing any any pushing of
the points on the King side we have King
to be one just a nice prophylactic move
and Knight to f6 now getting the nice -
to a more natural square we have f3 by
Magnus taking away efore NDG forefront
from the Dark Knight and now Queen to b6
developing the Queen still deciding
where the king is going to go where a
king said Queen side or maybe even stay
in the center although very unlikely
we have rook ht1 by Magnus now the
development is complete and allows me to
cut castles Queen side the same as
Magnus we see three by Magnus
strengthened in the center and the now
King to be it also a very nice
prophylactic move and now II four so
here Queen back to c7 and the now Queen
to g5 by Magnus putting pressure on the
g7 pawn the h4 pawn so you cannot defend
with this roxxon's differ
this work is stuck guarding the h4 pawn
you cannot put g6 because the knight
Hanks so this rook has to help out with
the defense and then now look the c1 by
Magnus preparing to push c4 and perhaps
open up the C file as now this rook left
left the Queen side and here we have
rook to h5 and already here there's a
bit of a difference in time our cousin
has 12 minutes on the clock whereas
logica has some 6 minutes and 30 seconds
on the clock we have Queen back the e3
by Magnus and now you have to decide
here you have to decide whether you want
to capture and then they said what to do
for example D captors on e4 Knights the
f4 just to push the rook back on my
solution soup and after rook ha8 just
captures on e4 and now black has a
couple of options that he can choose
from d v e5 g v you can go look to e8 a
lot of interesting ideas but instead of
this after Queen to e3 now we have E 5
right away which allows a Magnus this a
very intriguing idea of D captures on e5
d characters and now c4 and again you
have to make a choice so here you know
your your instincts tell you to push the
d4 pawn all this is all this is also
this is something you don't want to do
you want to either capture here and f4f
cappers any form just continue the game
or if you capture here you're gonna get
b3 now the point is pinned you cannot
capture anything and after all Isaac
will be 6 not allowing the capture here
you will see a queen trait and let's say
rook captures on c4 where
the game continues with equal material
although blacks bone structure is
somewhat compromised but d4 is not the
the best course of action for black as
now a Magnus gets this very strong C
pawn he doesn't push it I accidentally
did that he first of course half has to
move the Queen Queen e2 and now Knight
to d7 and c5 of course not allowing the
Knights to c5 so c5 and rooked h6 now
preparing to help out with the defense
so Magnus bushes before he wants to now
push everything get to the King perhaps
to help out with the defense push a 4 B
5 and so on we have Queen to c6 now
they're controlling this diagonal but
Magnus now helps out with the Queen
Queen B - now b5 is coming so Queen to
b5 blocking it and now Queen to b3
hoping to get a 4 in we have looked to a
6 keeping an eye on a4 but now just nice
to be 2 and here there is no good way to
prevent a 4 so look back to f6 as the f7
pawn is also under attack
but Magnus is not not interested in that
pawn he continues his play on the Queen
side we have pawn to a4 and now Queen to
c6 we have b5 pushing the Queen back and
Queen 36 now offering the Queen trade
and while you can go Queen to d5 here
you don't want to allow the straight
captures and to allow this pond to join
his friends so this would be playable
but Carlsen prefers the Queen's on the
board as a lodge Mischka is very low on
time so look back to c8 but still just
c6 we have nice the b6 now getting
getting out of the way but now a 5
pushing the night all the way into the
corner where Knights the a8 and now C
captures on b7 the threat is well just
capturing material here bringing a queen
entire game so King captures on b7 and
rook captures on CA we have Queen
captures and see it and rook the c1 you
are unable to stop this rooks influence
on the C file since rope the c6 is not
possible to do to the pawn queen back to
d8 and now Knight to d3
the knight is now coming
to c5 where it will be an extremely
strong night we have nice the c7 logica
tries to activate his night but now
night the c5 with check King today 8 and
now continuing the attack with b6 here
Magnus is not afraid of her opening up
the B file even though you know it does
look scary this rookie ever reaches b6
with your queen and king here it could
be it could be very dangerous but we
have a capture some b6 a capture some b6
and now Knight to a 6 point is if you go
Knights the e8 is just over for example
check you move check you move and now
going to be 7 is mate
so here Knights the a6 and here last
night I had the idea of if if Knight
captures here then just a root capture
Sun b6 winning the Queen however you
don't really win the Queen because you
have rip the c8 check and then it's it
or a queen trade or you just grab the
roof Queen captures now the rope is no
longer guarded and now you're just up a
knight in a winning position but Magnus
says ok I'm gonna not calculate that out
I'm just gonna go be summoned check and
capture the knight next because then my
knight will be an a6 guarding the
queening square so King the a7 and now
Knight captures on a6 and here we reach
the incredible moment from the title
over the video feel free to pause the
video and try to find the best move for
black while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on you
know taking the hint and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
it's rook to b6 rook to b6 is different
now than the previous rook to b6 a
logical play the rook captures on a6 but
look the b6 here is well it's it's the
best Chang chance black ass and I do
believe it's a draw but it's not
possible to calculate in a rapid game
especially not when you have so little
time on the clock the point is that now
it's not the same for example ok the
queen is under attack
and if you go b8 Queen you get Queen
captures on b8 and now Knight captures
on b8
rook captures on before width check came
to a2 and not just King captures here
you go into this end game where black is
up upon so that's a and already you have
a past deep on on d4 so not something
you want to do so after rook the b6 look
the c8 the same idea as before only now
it's a bit different it doesn't come
with check so here we have King captures
on a six and now pawn goes to b8 and you
promote it to a night with check so
point is King b7 now rook captures and
yet you grab the Queen but now rook
captures and b4 with check King to c2
and now white is up apiece but the
problem is next for example Roxy for
check you go King the three rope 3 a 3 C
check you go back King to be two and now
look the a three and there's no good way
to get your knight into the game you are
up a piece but there's nothing you can
do about it you cannot develop it all of
the scores are covered you can go Knight
d7 but ninja's King c7 forces the rogue
back and you win the night so a really
incredible stuff I I thought it was an
incredible moment that such an
opportunity presented itself in a game
but you know it's it's still hard to say
whether you would ever be able to get
the night into the game but I don't
think so I mean I mean if you get this
rook to e8 there's there's nothing you
can do about it
so it was a really really exciting stuff
but yeah after this kink the a7 Knight
captures on a6 logic ah trusted Carlson
and didn't even probably maybe maybe he
checked this but he thought that rook to
see it was just the same so he captured
the night but here Magnus just played
rook the c8 and it was in this position
that the victor lasa resigned the game
as now there really isn't anything to do
because here you're out of moves next
move b8 Queen will be made so you can
only play rook to b6 but now b8 Queen
comes with check and after you capture
it just Queen captures here you capture
the pawn and well you are up a queen and
the point and the rook so now really
really awesome stuff after you create
logical resigns and a very important
victory for Magnus Carlsen and not
because it's with his London system but
because he really he almost causes the
cat with the gap between him him and the
leaders he's now on six points whereas
Vanko and the midea of who drew your
game around six and a half so it's gonna
be gonna be exciting but still a lot of
rounds to go
so yeah once again I do hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank Leon and mark
sigue Alessio potaka a Simon Sevilla
Jill Berta and Julien your subs are they
for a contribution to my channel I think
you ought to really appreciate it as
usual you can check - in my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon
you already know that we are continuing
the coverage of the feeder world rapid
in blitz championship so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day